I'm Leah belletto with the Sky News
Daily and I'm at the high court in
London along with dozens of
photographers and Camera Crews from the
UK and across the world pavement
barriers aligning the road leading to
the entrance of the high court in
anticipation of Prince Harry's arrival
on Tuesday but as we're here recording
this outside Court things inside the
legal proceedings well they've wrapped
for the day and we've been watching the
legal teams leaving Wheeling their
trolleys full of legal documents
well it's a pertinent question
this is the start of a hearing that
we'll see a senior Royal giving evidence
in court for the first time in 130 years
this is Prince Harry's action against
mirror group newspapers he's suing the
Publishers of the Daily Mirror because
he claims he was a victim of unlawful
information gathering along with his
brother the Prince of Wales their mother
Diana and their father King Charles
[Music]
so I'm joined Now by media lawyer
Jonathan code and our Royal
correspondent Laura bondoc um what a day
it's been today you know the first
senior British member of the royal
family to give evidence since what the
19th century I was reminded of that
walking here first thing this morning
you walk past a big statue of Prince
Albert thinking oh my goodness that was
his son Edward VII was the last person
he was then Prince of Wales who had to
come to the high court to give evidence
from the witness and he only had to
appear for 20 minutes or so Harry's
ordeal while I'm schooling in her deal
but I don't think it's gonna be easy for
him will last a lot longer he wasn't
here today in court though we just had
the opening arguments of both sides but
we it set the scene I think for what
Harry can expect but it is a very very
significant moment the fact you have to
go back so far shows that this doesn't
happen the Royal Family do not like
seeing themselves in court Harry has
chosen this moment yes so Harry didn't
turn up but Jonathan the judge wasn't
happy with that what was the atmosphere
like inside
well right from the outset the two
Advocates locked horns that is clearly
going to be the context of this battle
because it inevitably it's to some
extent a combat between two Warriors
and David and the Casey for the the
mirror started arguing right at the
beginning about how much time each of
them will have for their case the judge
has set a three-day limit on this case
uh it's one of a whole load and so
they're they're arguing about who gets
more time to address the judge so right
from the outset that swords were drawn
okay so Prince Harry will arrive
tomorrow we know that he'll be here
tomorrow big moments today Laura we will
touch on some of those you know the
letters from Princess Diana to Michael
Barrow more bouts of depression from
Prince Harry after that breakup with
Chelsea Davey um but how did we get here
Laura Story
no we got here because Harry has made it
very clear he puts it this way his
life's work is to try and change the
media landscape he believes that from a
very young age and today we heard about
that how from the age of 11 his life was
essentially hacked into his phone was
hacked into private investigators were
deployed to look into him there was
blagging so the deceptive ways they were
trying to get personal private
information about him all of this simply
to sell newspapers that is what he's all
about here he he could have settled this
case but he wants his moment in court he
wants these Revelations to come out so
we hear about them so he can have them
discussed and he ultimately wants those
who were responsible he believes those
at the very top knew exactly what was
going on he wants them held to account
and in some cases thrown into jail those
are his words those are his allegations
and Jonathan this isn't the only case
that Prince Harry is bringing against
the Press no he's not and he's declared
full-on war against them and as someone
who has fought the Press on behalf of
everything from celebrities footballers
to Ordinary People I can tell you that
fighting the Press is not for the
faint-hearted now Harry of course is a
warrior he fought the Taliban but when
you fight the press in court it is not
generally according to the mark of
Marcus crisby rules they defend
themselves and I regret to say I have
seen some pretty Grim stuff
Grim conduct by lawyers active in
newspapers over the years and in fact if
you look at the Judgment of Mr Justice
Warby as it then was in the claim which
is which Meghan Markle brought against
the the mail on Sunday he was very rude
about the defense Council and their case
in that case it was it's clear that that
the newspaper decided they were just
going to make life hard despite the fact
they had no defense look says there's a
better defense here but Harry is going
to get roasted tomorrow in the witness
box they're not going to spare him and
he's going to need nerves of Steel to
get through it
in all his other you know interviews
he's always been in control of that so
it will be quite explosive but let's
talk about today before we get to
tomorrow because it was quite
interesting is it the his lawyer
focusing on those 33 articles in
particular they're the ones that have
been selected so there are lots more you
know we've heard that there were 147
thousands basically but there were 33
articles which they think they have a
strong case to prove that these articles
were the product of or involved bits of
information it was unlawfully gathered
basically and so these articles go all
the way back to when Harry was a boy not
even a teenager from 11. really really
young and article you know when his
mother was still alive you go right the
way through his personal his family is
private in his professional life and I
think what we saw today is how they're
trying to paint this picture of it just
being endemic when it came to Harry
constantly there it was a habitual thing
with him the mirror delicious completely
but you know when we heard about um
Diana his mother how her voicemail was
hacked it revealed these secret kind of
conversations and meetings she'd had
with the Entertainer Michael Barrymore
as she was devastated that information
came out how he stopped getting in touch
with her she didn't know why and it was
you know he thought she was leaking she
had no idea and now this is what Harry's
Harry Harry is alleging we heard more
also about the let me move this
microphone closer to my mouth and we
heard more about
um the relationship with his brother
William how there was a sense that they
had a falling out the details of that
falling out have been made public very
early on and how this had sewn some
seeds of Discord as it was put in court
the sense that it was fueling and
fostering a mistrust between them that
led to paranoia the trust they had the
bomb they had as brothers eroded away
and I think matters we know lots about
now how they've fallen out the rift
they've had it is well documented isn't
it but we're seeing that was this
perhaps being played out very early on
as a result of how the Press was
negatively covering that relationship
that's certainly what Harry is claiming
here and there was also lots of talk
about Chelsea Davey and how much that
relationship was hounded by the Press oh
Non-Stop and and you know of the 33
articles 12 are about their relationship
so that's a big thing here how they were
kids basically they were very young
weren't they teenagers she was still at
school when they met and how they never
felt like they were alone that I think
played a massive part in it doesn't it
it was bombshell wasn't it Jonathan well
it is but what strikes me is the extent
of the wickedness that's being exposed
here
you know I have had three clients of
mine
um in the in the public eye who've
attempted suicide what this shows is the
extent to which the Tabloid press which
is not properly regulated and this is
one of Harry's big beats and he's right
about it what they therefore are free to
do and he I feel very strongly in
support of him because he's carrying the
banner for thousands and thousands of
people who can't afford lawyers who
can't afford to ignore the vast sums
which he will have been offered because
we we know that William has accepted a
very large summer money in settlement we
can also say for absolute certain that
Harry will have been offered a very
large sum of money but he doesn't care
it's not what he's here for it's not for
money it's to hold these people to
account now I think he is absolutely
right to do so and he's Brave in doing
so as it's some risk to himself because
it's possible tomorrow is not a low low
risk exercise okay financially you can
afford to lose although it'll be a lot
of money if he does but he could have it
finding against him effectively that
that the judge doesn't believe what he
says now that is a massive risk today I
don't think it'll happen but he's really
put himself on the line here but I think
good on him and then Laura obviously
Andrew Green Casey came out fighting
sort of saying you know Harry's
extensive claims there's no evidence
that they're true yeah so I think what
he was trying to say is that despite the
fact that we know there are lots and
lots of invoices to private
investigators does that mean they were
illegally obtaining information and does
it mean that what information they were
getting was then creating these stories
he's saying the you've got a big jump
basically between that situation an
invoice to a pi and a story popping up
in a newspaper and you know that Gap is
the one that Harry has to try and close
or join the dots work with if you like
what will be interesting I think about
when Harry gives evidence when Harry's
in the witness standards so far
everything we've heard from Harry every
time he's opened his math and we've
heard a lot it's been on his terms
tomorrow will be completely different it
is not going to be on his terms they're
going to rip shreds through any kind of
they'll want to yeah and he can't be
told what to say he can be advised and
he can be told we suggest you think
about these questions but they won't be
able to put words in his mouth and Laura
Majors makes a very good point I mean
I've prepared Witnesses for years and I
I guess that they'll do what I would do
if I was Harry's lawyer I would
cross-examine him
I would sit down and I ask myself okay
what are the likely questions and I
cross-examine them though what I
absolutely can't do and would not do is
give them the answers but what I can do
is preparing for the likely areas he's
going to be questioned so that it's less
like he'll be caught off guard because
that KC is not going to spare him and
he's a Casey for a good reason he's good
so yeah and Harry you know is not a
lawyer this is this is not familiar
ground to me he's probably happier with
a rifle that than he is in the courtroom
so I'm sure that his team I'm sure
entirely properly has done all they can
to de-risk the cross-examination best
they can but there is no way you can
de-esque it fully so he's still very
much on the line Laura I want you to
just talk us through what will happen
for the next few days but what very
quickly what impact do you think this
will have on the royal family they'll be
watching this won't they they will be
watching it and they will be very
grateful it is none of them doing this
William would have had the chance to do
exactly this he didn't want to he wanted
to settle out of court Harry wants these
details made public that's why he's
coming I think what we'll see is a huge
amount of breasts in here outside the
court I mean today was the tip of the
iceberg it's going to be enormous
they'll be pressed of all over the world
wanting to cover this Harry wants that
coverage but he has to be very careful
because he is talking about the press in
a negative way he says he hasn't got an
A Vendetta against the press in general
that he wants to use his platform for
the greater good he has his bigger
Mission this bigger purpose if you like
but it will be very interesting to see
how it plays out for him it could go
either way and it is a huge personal
risk I know that the king isn't in the
country at the moment he's very
conveniently on holiday in Transylvania
we're not going to be hearing from any
of them there will be no comment about
this there hasn't ever been they say
it's ongoing legal proceedings I'm sure
they'll be worried about what he's going
to say but they all know Harry does
things his way and there is no stopping
him okay so Tuesday Harry takes to the
stand Wednesday Cross examing of Harry
is that the is that the timetable
um no he will be cross-examined straight
away tomorrow oh okay so so just to
explain what will happen is that his own
Barrister will take him to the stand he
will then be given the he'll then take
the oath
um David chairborne will say
um uh is this your witness statement and
Harry will say yes I said you do you can
can you confirm the contents of that was
Tomatoes true and he'll say yes at that
point the witness statement is sworn and
at that point David Sherborne sits down
and that the mirror KC stands up and
gives it the full whack so that'll be
all of tomorrow
and half a day on Wednesday now what
happened this morning was that the there
was an argument about how long the case
he had to cross-examined him and the
case he said a day isn't enough my Lord
I want a day and a half and the judge
said you know what I think that's fair
enough so he's been given an extra half
a day and they're going to be very
exciting times okay thank you so much
Laura and Jonathan appreciate your time
thank you
[Music]
my thanks to Laura Jonathan and to you
for listening to the Sky News Daily with
me Leah belletto this episode was
produced by Annie Joyce with Sydney peed
the editors Philly Beaumont
and just to let you know there's a
special Sky News program on TV at nine
o'clock each evening reflecting on the
day's Court proceedings so if you're
listening to this after they're played
out you can watch it back on our mobile
app and YouTube channel
[Music]